el más reciente informe de la revista
médica británica de lancet es un llamado
las armas contra el cambio climático los
autores esperan que la evidencia del
reporte muestre la necesidad de una
acción urgente menos de dos semanas
antes de que las naciones se reúnan en
las conversaciones climáticas de la ONU
en Egipto mientras el mundo trata de
recuperarse de la pandemia de Kobe 19 la
recuperación se ve obstaculizada por los
impactos negativos del cambio climático
en la salud y sus determinantes lo que
enfatiza la necesidad urgente de actuar
el estudio incluye el trabajo de casi
100 investigadores de todo el mundo
destacan 43 indicadores en los que el
cambio climático está afectando la Salud
si abatido récords de temperatura en
todo el mundo en 2022
en el Reino Unido las temperaturas
superaron los 40 grados Celsius por
primera vez en el mes de julio Mientras
que otras partes de Europa Pakistán y
China también experimentaron nunca los
récord alelojear el informe el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez fue aún más directo que los
médicos la crisis climática nos está
matando está socavando no solo la salud
de nuestro planeta sino también la salud
de las personas en todas partes a través
de la contaminación tóxica del aire la
disminución de la seguridad alimentaria
mayores riesgos de brotes de
enfermedades infecciosas calor extremo
récord sequía inundaciones y más
Se esperan acalorado cebates en las
conversaciones de la cop 27 en Egipto el
próximo mes los países en desarrollo
esperarán que las naciones que se
hicieron ricas usando combustibles
fósiles compensen el daño que está
causando el cambio climático pero las
naciones más ricas están distraídas por
la guerra en Ucrania por la crisis el
costo de la vida y una inflación
vertiginosa